hey how's it going bros my name is
sporty PHA and this is a really tough
video just don't come to my house please
are we done are we done that was it I
think this video will be some sort of
public service announcement where I
speak for many if not all youtubers also
saying what should be obvious so really
I don't know what's the point since I
started doing YouTube I've lived in sex
it's gonna go 7 or 6 and then he went
sex that's pretty funny I lived in saks
different locations and I've had fans
coming up to each and every single one
of them and here's the big surprise it's
[ __ ] weird it's so weird it's so
[ __ ] weird it's so weird it's uh oh
just stop picture it like this I don't
know who you are but I know that you
found my address online and thought hey
I'm gonna invite myself over from my
perspective that's just insane I've even
had parents coming over with their kids
I've had people yell outside my house I
had school classes come outside just
because you found my address doesn't
mean you found an invitation for you to
come over this should be obvious and I
know a lot of people that will say well
you're a youtuber you signed up for this
life now you got a deal with it it's
like no [ __ ] no okay
just because I have an audience doesn't
mean I have to be okay with bad behavior
that's so stupid and I also know that
videos like these tend to make people
think well he really doesn't care about
expands that's it so don't get me wrong
I love meeting you breasts 99% of the
time is an amazing experience and it
makes me understand that what I do here
every single day in front of the
computer has real impact that's
something I never want taken away but if
you do come to my house I will not greet
you and I will not take a picture with
you and if you came from really far away
well I'm sorry you shouldn't have done
this is about my privacy and I think if
you bros are in the same situation you
would want the same thing for yourself
so thank you for understanding
don't come to youtubers houses because
it's weird and thank you guys so much
love you guys so much and as always